you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
departing for crucial international
climate meetings in europe president
biden says he's making progress at home
countdown to glasgow three days until
the global climate summit cop 26 begins
in scotland and organisers are talking
down chances of success
and ai weiwei artist turned climate
activist speaks exclusively to sky news
and says china is capable of change on
climate
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now in the last few moments president
biden has left washington for europe and
crucial international meetings on
climate first the g20 in italy their
next stop on to glasgow for him for cop
26. before leaving the president has
been in talks on capitol hill to try and
get his infrastructure plans through
congress critical to his
administration's action on climate
he called the proposed spending the most
significant investment that's ever been
made by a developed nation
over a billion metric tons of emission
reductions
at least 10 times bigger on climate than
any bill that has ever passed before and
enough to position us for a 50 to 52
emission reductions by the year 2030
and we'll do it in ways that grow the
domestic industries create good paying
union jobs
address long-standing environmental
injustices as well
well our u.s correspondent mark stone is
in washington to put all this into
context for us hello to you mark what
does this mean in terms of america's
spending on climate measures and how
does it leave the u.s leadership going
into glasgow
it leaves them in a very very precarious
situation you heard what he said there
it sounded positive very positive
language but the the fact is he does not
have a deal he has a framework for a
deal he wanted a deal to be able to take
with him to glasgow what he's trying to
do sally is is to push through two
whopping bits of legislation worth
several trillion dollars and people on
his own side democrats are worried about
the amount of money he is spending and
they're worried specifically about some
of the climate provisions within
that legislation joe manchin is a
democrat senator from west virginia
where coal is a massive industry he for
one is very wary about any any idea of
cutting and shutting down coal plants so
what we're left with is joe biden going
to glasgow and going to rome before that
without a deal now the the whole um the
united states reputation rests on joe
biden being able to go to glasgow and
saying look this is what you're do we're
doing the rest of the world needs to
follow through we've already seen that
china when um joe biden's envoy john
kerry says to china you need to do more
for climate change china falls back and
says well look at the last president
donald trump pulled out of the paris
climate talks how do we know that the
americans won't do that again in another
election in four years time so
i have to say right now you say it's
looking pessimistic for glasgow on your
side of the atlantic it is here too we
have a framework of a deal but it is
already a deal that's been watered down
also happening in washington today mark
a congressional hearing with big oil and
gas companies about what they've known
about the damage they've been doing to
the planet and for how long what have
you heard
yeah this is being described by
democrats who called this uh this this
hearing as some sort of a a tobacco
moment for the oil industry i don't
think it is that was we've seen the uh
the key uh leaders of the the big oil
giants uh testifying on capitol hill
being asked whether they knew about the
damage fossil fuels have been doing for
years and years no surprise the answer
is they say they have covered up nothing
we do not spread disinformation
regarding climate change so says exxon
mobil's chief executive this is an
ongoing hearing it is a moment that
they're there they're testifying under
oath but i don't think we should expect
any massive surprises very interesting
indeed mark stone thank you very much
indeed for talking us through all that
now it's just three days until joe biden
and most of the rest of the world's
leaders arrive in glasgow for cop26 the
global conference being held to pursue
solutions to the climate crisis
the key to these meetings is to find a
way to bring down emissions and keep
global warming under control the uk as
hosts are under pressure to bring
everyone to the table and now the
world's biggest emitter china has
submitted has submitted its latest plans
let's speak now to our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter hanna
will china's new plan make a difference
well
on paper
not necessarily an obvious one but if
you read it carefully the language has
been tweaked in an important way it's
original target said that the nation
which is the world's largest polluter
right now
would get to peak carbon emissions
around 2030 and make efforts for that to
be sooner or earlier but its new plan
submitted on the eve of cop says that
peak carbon emissions are going to
happen before 2030 and we've heard that
language being used
just days from the cop 26 un climate
summit in glasgow we meet the events
president alok sharma in downing street
there's a long shopping list of problems
that need to be sorted out
china needs to commit to more there
needs to be an agreement on phasing out
coal it looks like cop26 is in real
trouble
look you're absolutely right i mean this
is going to be difficult this is going
to be a big big challenge this is
getting almost 200 countries to reach
consensus on some of these difficult
issues that have been outstanding for
six years now it is in the balance
adding to the strain the un has just
issued a dire warning that the world is
way off track in limiting temperature
rises to a safe threshold
the united nations secretary general
said that the issue was a leadership gap
is it a problem with your leadership my
job as cop 26 president is effectively
to act as shepherd in chief but
ultimately this does come down to world
leaders delivering on their commitments
uh you know i i can't force any one
country to do anything
that definitely applies to china it has
already committed to peak emissions by
2030 and net zero by 2060 but global
targets will be missed if the world's
largest polluter isn't more ambitious
it is china that matters though above
all do you accept that uh well
absolutely china china is the biggest
emitter china matters uh but you know
soon so
they are the biggest emitter by that by
that very statement so if they don't
move cop is in jeopardy
just about all the g20 17 out of the 20
have said that they're going to um go to
net zero by the middle of the century
that is a move but of course that's
that's not enough what keeps me up at
night is uh just yeah thinking about the
complexity of this what we want is for
us to win for the world to collectively
win so that we can say to you know our
generation but also the future
generations that we delivered when it
mattered
that's the ambition
geopolitics may get in the way
in a few days time we'll find out
so the world is heading into glasgow
with significant head weak winds because
of what's happened today really you know
does biden have a domestic deal on
climate change legislation no has india
committed to a net zero carbon emission
goal no has china made a big move that
might
change the calculus of how other
developing countries might behave
no so it is no wonder then that alok
sharma the man at the very center of
this summit the cop 26 president has
told sky news that the whole thing as it
stands is hanging in the balance
hannah thomas peter thank you very much
and in today's other climate news sir
david attenborough has called on world
leaders to listen to the science and
take powerful action in glasgow next
week he was speaking at a ceremony to
mark the first voyage of a polar
research ship which is named after him
it will set off on its first ever
antarctic expedition later this year
would it not be marvelous to suppose
that as a consequence of our discoveries
and that science is discovery
that the nations of the world
joined together
and actually did something
at cop in this coming conference let us
see what it does
but i hope and pray that my goodness it
takes action
that the nations of the world in the
light of the scientific discoveries that
this ship
will undoubtedly be making
that nations got together and listened
to the silence
of what has to be done
if the world is not to be overcome
by catastrophe
extinction rebellion activists have
broken into britain's biggest oil
refinery protesters including two
british olympians chained themselves to
various structures at exxon mobil's site
in forly in hampshire the group is
calling on the government to stop
investing in fossil fuels and to end
expansion plans for the site
and some of the world's most protected
forests are emitting more carbon than
they absorb due to human activity
new research by unesco has found that at
least 10 world heritage forests
including yosemite national park in the
u.s have started adding carbon to the
atmosphere over the past 20 years
researchers say pressures such as
illegal logging wood harvesting and
livestock grazing are putting forests at
risk
ai weiwei came to prominence as an
artist who fled china after he spoke out
against the government there
he left his home country in 2015 but now
with his focus on environmental activism
he says china is capable of change and
can play its part in solving the climate
crisis he's spoken exclusively to our
correspondent katie spencer
on display at piccadilly circus ai
weiwei is asking where do we go from
here
part of the circa art movement this
challenge comes just ahead of cop 26 as
known for his political activism as his
art now he's speaking out on climate
change we always point the finger to
others
deforestation
and
pollution
all done by a human
he fears the climate conference might
not make much difference
probably it's too late
and the most likely
nothing will change we cannot depend on
one
meeting
famously designing the bird's nest
stadium for the 2008 beijing olympics
life became increasingly difficult for
ai weiwei after he spoke out against the
chinese government he eventually left
china in 2015 but the artist defends how
his home country's greenhouse emissions
have come to exceed all developed
nations pointing out that china's 1.4
billion people per capita produce less
greenhouse emissions than the us
what china did every nation did before
so
to use one standard to to measure
everything which is very colonial and
very discriminative whatever agreements
are reached at cop26 ai weiwei believes
china is capable of change
once they made a clear policy
they can
follow their
their decisions
and
if they really want they can do
do
anything tool
to achieve their plan
the artist who has always spoken out
against the status quo says we all need
to take a stand
if you don't act
or if you're not conscious about what is
going wrong
i think
it's a tragic to your own life
i think
this is a
responsibility of being human to take
care of human conditions
for ai weiwei not only is it clear that
we need to act on climate he believes
it's also time to look at how we in the
west are quick to point the finger
katie spencer sky news
and do stay with us because coming up
after the break i'll be joined by
climate scientist dr ella gilbert and
international ambassador of the
conservative environment network stanley
johnson there they are standing by we'll
be discussing if climate talks at cop26
need to focus more on present or future
challenges and what we can learn from
polar exploration that's next stay with
us
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with climate
scientist dr ella gilbert and
international ambassador of the
conservative environment network stanley
johnson a very warm welcome to you both
now just days before the summit there
are growing concerns about the outcome
of cop26 but the climate crisis is
already here and there's no time to lose
so do leaders need to switch their focus
to what's happening now rather than what
might happen should cop 26 focus on
present problems or future challenges
stanley johnson to you first the prime
minister himself said recently that they
may not reach the agreements they need
it's touch and go it's very difficult
what solutions in your opinion should
leaders be focusing on at cop
well i think they've got to go they've
got to go for an agreement on the track
we're on we have to get the world back
bend the curve back so that two degrees
even 1.5 degrees is reasonable but the
other thing is to celebrate i'm optimist
today very good news that china has said
we're going to advance the date or do
our best to advance the date of peaking
that is something i'm not one of these
turnovers they have made a huge effort
they're going to go from peaking to
neutrality in a shorter space of time
than almost any other country in the
world
and dr ella gilbert climate finance
needs to grow 13 times faster to achieve
these climate targets do you think
enough leaders are going to get their
checkbook out at cop26
well i wouldn't like to comment on the
kind of policy negotiations but they
absolutely have to as a scientist i can
comment only really on what's happened
and what is likely to happen
and the truth of the matter is that
we're already seeing huge impacts of
climate change we're already seeing
devastating impacts all over the world
and those impacts are likely to get much
worse if we do not do anything and that
means world leaders putting their money
where their mouth is and actually
implementing those mitigating
climate action proposals so they
absolutely have to um in my mind
and stanley johnson just to you how
concerning is it to you that some of the
biggest polluters either aren't going or
haven't yet uh confirmed their
attendance do you think this is just a
sign that perhaps it won't be taken
seriously enough
no i think we've got a very good there's
a very good show
for us in glasgow i think we are going
to get a good result and the point
you're just making about adaptation
money for developing countries is
perfectly crucial well said ella because
actually those countries africa whatever
they didn't create the problem and yet
they are going to suffer the impact so
money for adaptation crucial
well let's move on to our next issue of
the day you may be familiar with the
polar exploration vessel that was almost
named boaty mcboatface well it's now
called the rrs sir david attenborough
and it made its debut today in london
but what is it that we can learn about
the climate crisis from polar
exploration to dr ella gilbert first
we know ice caps are melting we know sea
levels are rising is polar exploration
still relevant
absolutely it can't be more relevant
it's
really really important to understand
what's happening at the polls because
the polar regions are the canary and the
coal mine for climate change as you
mentioned the ice caps are melting that
has
impacts all over the world in in terms
of sea level rise
and if we can understand what's
happening now in the regions we can
understand what happened in the past
then we can better predict the future
and that of course helps us to
understand how best to adapt and also
what we need to do to mitigate the worst
impacts of climate change
and stanley johnson arctic sea ice has
almost halved since
1980 it's losing an area the equivalent
of half the size of england every year
now if the world does manage to stick to
that 1.5 degree target will that be
enough
look i want to say this story brings
back most happy memories to me i spent
six weeks in 1984 going around with
indeed the
david ashman was precursor it was called
the john bisco with the british
antarctic seven i wrote a book called
antarctica the last great wilderness and
that then was talking about the loss of
ice in the polar regions of the
antarctic and and the arctic and yes we
have to go 1.5 will perhaps enable us to
keep a lot of the polarized but i heard
by no means all those polar bears you
see them in southward they are trapped
that they are trapped at three thousand
people who can't get onto the ice this
is a tragedy
and dr gilbert uh we know the arctic is
often
regarded as the ground zero of climate
change it's heating more than three
times more quickly than anywhere else on
the planet is it now a case of just
saving what we can
i think it's never too late to take
meaningful action and absolutely every
single ton of co2 matters when it comes
to climate change absolutely every
single tenth of a degree matters when it
comes to sea ice loss or arctic change
or the loss of ice in ice sheets and
glaciers because all of those
tenths of degrees translates into
millimeters or even meters of sea level
rise so every single action we take now
matters and that means every single one
of us but also every single nation and
doing absolutely everything we can we
need to throw everything in the kitchen
sink at this problem
and just briefly stanley before we let
you go how much can we learn from
wildlife
we can well enormously wildlife is a
crucial part of this and one good thing
that's right obviously one good thing is
the leaders the world leaders are going
to adopt a state of nature declaration
of save the forest save the land use is
absolutely important because nature the
protection of nature is a crucial part
of this 30 for everything we do will
need to be done through the protection
of wildlife and land use and i very much
hope that mr bolsonaro president
baltimore
really says the crucial thing is amongst
other things to say johnson dr ella
gilbert we have to leave it there thank
you very much indeed we'll see you next
time
[Music]